[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATHY WANG: I'm Kathy
Wang, senior director
of security at GitLab.
Thank you very much
for taking the time
to come to listen to GitLab's
journey on Zero Trust today.
And this is my
colleague Phillippe,
and we're going to talk
to you about Zero Trust.
So what I want to do since
this is an intermediate level
talk is make sure everyone
is on the same page
with what we mean by
Zero Trust, and then we
want to talk about
the specific problems
that we face at GitLab
that we were trying
to address with
Zero Trust roll out,
which is one of our biggest
initiatives this year in 2019.
And then, of course, I'll
talk about the roadmap
and how we came
about building this.
And I definitely want
you to be able to learn
from our experience so far
and take this home with you
as you build your
Zero Trust journey.
So lessons learned will
also be a part of our talk.
Traditionally, what do we do
as security practitioners?
We set up a perimeter-based
defense system, right.
That's our defensing that most
of this security industry does.
And we all know
this really well.
It's the hard on
the outside and soft
on the inside kind
of architecture
where if an attacker gets
access inside your environment,
they can move laterally.
They can persist.
They can elevate privileges.
They can do all of these things.
And we know as an industry, this
does not really work that well.
But most of us employ those
type of architecture anyway.
So what I want to highlight
is so why Zero Trust?
So Google has a
flavor of Zero trust
that they've built backing
through our early 2010s,
and they call it BeyondCorp.
So if you want to
read more about that,
they have a ton of white papers,
great websites with content.
This is their flavor
of Zero Trust.
I'm using the term Zero Trust
because every environment
has different requirements.
In our case and in most people's
case, what Zero Trust means
is that all devices that are
trying to access an end point
or asset in your environment
needs to be authenticated
and authorized as they do so.
The user has to be
verified, validated.
We have to know what department
or what role they have.
And then we can decide whether
they should get access to what
they're trying to access.
All of these decisions,
by the way, are dynamic.
They're risk-based.
So it depends on the sensitivity
of the data on the host
that they're trying to access.
So for example, if I
use my personal device
to try to access a production
level database that
has customer data on
it and customer data
is high sensitivity, that
decision should be a no.
You cannot do that.
You have to use some sort
of corporate managed device
to access that, and you have
to be in the right role.
You have to be someone
who should have access
to the production DB.
There's somewhat
a lot of confusion
about what Zero Trust is.
This year at RSA--
how many people went to RSA?
OK, so a smathering of people.
They did a really
hilarious video--
you've got our look this up--
where they went around RSA
and they asked people, just
random people,
what is Zero Trust?
What's your definition of it?
Half the people didn't
know what it was, right.
I don't know if this
is a surprise to you
but it kind of is to
me, because Zero Trust
is one of the top three buzz
phrases at RSA this year.
So how does that add up?
I don't know.
But this is great video.
It's hilarious.
So what I want to
do here is I want
to define what Zero Trust
is not just in case.
If you think you can buy a
single product on the market,
slap that into your environment,
and now you've got Zero Trust,
you're wrong.
And if vendors tell you
that, they're wrong.
OK, this is not a product
that you can just put in.
It's a process.
You have to build
many components,
and those components
and how they're built
is going to vary depending
on your environment, what
your users are situated as,
and what your requirements are
and what kind of data
you're trying to protect.
The other common
misconception about Zero Trust
is that it's new.
That's certainly how
it came across the RSA
this year, right.
The reality is
that it's not new.
Way back in 2005 and
maybe even before that,
there were working groups of
security practitioners that had
already met, talked about their
problems like we always do--
we love to talk about our
problems with security--
and figure it out that, hey,
we have to figure out how
to the de-perimeterize
our environments,
because those particular
crunchy on the outside and soft
on the inside kind of model,
who is that working for, right?
Pretty much no one.
So it's not a new concept.
It's been talked about before.
Usually companies that
implement Zero Trust do it
after a major breach
has already occurred.
That's kind of
the reality of it.
And for cloud native companies
of which GitLab is definitely
a cloud native company,
80% of these companies
have not implemented Zero Trust
or even started on the process.
20% have and usually
after a major breach.
So I'm not-- so what I'm
saying is that at GitLab we're
trying to implement this
before a major breach.
So what are the benefits
to having Zero Trust?
I think it's pretty
clear, so I'm not
going to go ahead and read
all of these out to you.
You can read it yourself.
But fundamentally, you
just need to understand
that this changes the
model that traditionally we
deploy perimeters, and we
define basically every end
point in our environment
as a separate perimeter.
That's the idea.
So what happens when an
attacker gains access
to one of your
user's credentials.
Well, you have multiple
factor authentication
in place and maybe a
hardware token, for example.
And that will make the
credentials a whole lot less
useful for the
attacker by themselves.
What will happen when
attackers do get access
to one of the hosts
in your environment?
Which we all know in security--
and this has been
evolving for the 20 years
that I've been doing
security myself--
it's not whether you will
get compromised or not.
Many places do get compromised.
It's about being transparent
about what's happening,
making sure your customers know.
And then the other
thing is about how
you recover from that incident.
That's very important.
So what attackers will do
is try to move laterally
into your environment
once they get in.
And Zero Trust would make
that a lot more challenging.
So what we're going to see is
many more targeted attacks,
and it's going to have
to be very targeted.
It's going to take
a lot of resources.
I'm not going to sit
up here and tell you
that Zero Trust is 100% secure.
Because then I would be lying,
because security is never 100%.
But you have to understand
it's an ongoing process.
A couple of caveats,
I want to make sure
that everyone knows this.
You can't build Zero Trust
in a month or a week.
It is a journey that probably
will take you at least nine
to 12 months to do.
And that's assuming
that you have
all of the corporate
backing that you
need to do that, right.
That's also part of it.
I will go into a lot more
detail about that later.
And everything that I am
going to talk about today,
all the components that
we considered at the lab
as part of our journey it's
not the totality of everything
you're going to consider
for your Zero Trust journey.
Because you will have a
different environment.
Your users will be different.
What you're trying to
protect will be different.
So learn from us but
don't think that this
is all there is to it.
So let me go into now before
we started on the Zero Trust
journey and deciding how
we're going to roadmap
and build this out.
What did we have in
place already at GitLab?
And to give you a little
bit more background
about the security
team at GitLab,
I joined GitLab about
a year and a half ago.
And at the time
that I joined, there
wasn't a formal
security team, right.
So think about
that for a second.
A year and a half ago there
wasn't a security team.
So now we have a
team of almost 30.
This helps a lot, of course,
but it's been a journey
just to get there also.
So I don't know how big
your security teams are,
but that's a factor.
So what we had already
one of the first things
that I set out to build was
a data classification policy.
And why is that important?
Because it's going to govern
what data is being processed
or stored in your environment
and what levels of sensitivity
they are, right.
So for example for us, customer
data is of highest priority.
That's going to be
in a red data bucket,
and we bucketize the data
types by red, orange, yellow,
and green.
So from there, we
know as we build
out our environment and
our Zero Trust components
where to focus on first, right.
Focus on the red data first.
That's the highest sensitivity.
So having that policy
in place and having
that blessed by
everybody at the company
is a great step forward.
We also built a Google Cloud
Security guidelines policy,
and what that means is
we have an infrastructure
team at GitLab that builds
GitLab.com and they ensure
the availability of GitLab.com,
which is our SAS product.
And we have 2 million
plus users on GitLab.com.
How did they build
that environment?
Are they following
security best practices?
Are they using
VPCs, for example,
to compartmentalize
different environments.
Are they providing access
correctly and to best practices
guidelines?
To me a policy is
just a piece of paper
unless we actually enforce it.
So we use tools
like Google Forseti,
for example, to enforce
the GCP security guidelines
portion of it.
We also built an internal
acceptable use policy,
because our users should
know what's expected behavior
and what's not OK behavior,
right, in our environment.
Basically here the rules apply,
right, in GitLab.com production
environments.
Without that,
people do whatever,
and you have to rely
on good intentions.
And that's never a good idea.
We also have an HR
Database in place,
and I mention this because
part of Zero Trust components
is making sure
you know who's who
and what organization they're
in and what role they're in
and what access they should
have based on that role.
So until you know this, you
cannot make that risk-based
decision that I was
talking about earlier.
One thing that's very
special to GitLab--
and I don't know how
many people in here
work at a 100% remote company--
but what that
means is people are
connecting from 50 plus
different countries
around the world.
We don't have a physical
building at GitLab.
That's a very, very
special requirement
in our case that may or
may not apply to you.
But what that means as a
security practitioner to me
is that I really have to
focus on credential and access
management of those users.
I can't monitor
their home networks.
I can't monitor their cafes
that they're connecting from.
There's no physical
office that everyone's
coming into or VPNing in
through that environment
first before accessing anything
that doesn't work that way.
So we have to think
about that portion of it.
We don't do any self-hosting
of any services.
A lot of companies run
their own email servers.
We don't even do that, right.
We use our G Suite.
We use Google Gmail, and we
rely on Google Security best
practices to help make sure.
For example, Google
Enterprise has a DLP feature.
So for sensitive
documents we might
be able to update DLP
information to say,
hey, don't allow any
documents with these key words
to be able to be sent out
to the public, for example.
So we have to rely on
third-party SaaS providers
for everything.
We don't self host.
We also have an
environment where everyone
is using Mac OS and Linux.
We don't have Windows
in the environment.
You may, so your mileage
is going to vary if you do,
because there's different
requirements there
and different OSs to deal with.
So we have a fairly
homogeneous environment
I would call it from
a security standpoint.
Now that I've told you what
we had in place already,
let's talk about
the first problem
that we're looking to solve.
There's going to be a
series of three problems.
I'll talk about the
first and the third,
and Philippe will
talk about the second.
But the first problem is
managing those users, right,
where, as I said,
we're connecting
from all over the world.
So how exactly do
we know who they
are, what they are trying to
access, what type of device
are they using to access
that, and is it OK
for them to access that data?
So we set out to answer
a series of questions
in considering this problem.
We looked at endpoints.
We need to know not just
the endpoints meaning
the laptop, the user laptops
or devices, but the endpoints
in our production
environment in things
that we manage on our own in
Google Cloud, for example.
And so we looked at tools
like Uptics and Kilidem
because we're a Linux,
and Mac OS shop.
See this is why I
said this matters.
If your windows, then you're
looking at other tools
potentially.
But we looked at
these tools, which
is based on OSquery, which
is very important to us
to gain awareness of what
those endpoints look like.
Building that information
into an asset database
is key, right.
So the other piece
of it is who are
these people that
are trying to connect
and should they be
able to connect.
So having an org
chart and an org DB
is something that we
also have to build,
and that's going to be based
off of our HR database.
We also want to-- we're
growing so fast as a company
that when I joined a
year and a half ago,
I was probably employee
number 200 something,
and now there's over 500
people a year and a half later.
And in another year, we're
anticipating over 1,000.
So think about this from a
security management standpoint.
You have people on-boarding and
off-boarding every week, like,
a lot of people potentially.
And a big security risk is to
have people leave the company
and then still not be updated
in your database, right.
Think about how
scary that would be.
That's really not ideal.
So being able to
on-board, off-board,
get people access
to the third party
apps that they need access
to to do their work.
We looked at solutions like
Okta, Duo, Google's Cloud
Identity.
These are all solutions that
you would consider when you're
thinking about this problem.
We also looked at that
multi-factor authentication
piece.
In our case, we considered
hardware tokens.
Like that makes credential that
less valuable to an attacker.
So we considered UB Keys.
We considered Google's
Titan Security Keys.
So these are all pieces that
you should also look at.
And how are we
effectively enforcing
our data classification policy?
It goes back to that, right.
Anything that's in
a red bucket that
is considered most sensitive,
we have to protect that first.
And that's our highest priority.
So these are the types of
questions that we ask for that.
And now we come to problem two,
and Philippe will talk to you.
PHILIPPE LAFOUCRIERE:
Thank you very much, Kathy.
By the way, I'm
Philippe Lafourcriere.
I'm a distinguished
engineer at GitLab.
I'm working in
the security team.
We are working on the
security features of GitLab.
So that's why we're going
to talk about securing
our applications.
So we've seen so far
how Zero Trust can
help us securing our
network perimeter allowing
the admins to set up and
enforce policies to protect
this network and allow users and
devices to access our resources
and applications.
But it doesn't make any sense if
we have these policies in place
and attackers can bypass
them, because we are
shipping insecure applications.
So how do we trust what's
running on our production
environments?
The first step is to make
sure that the applications
themselves are secure.
In the last year, we have
switched left to this--
we have switched security
to the left at GitLab.
That was a huge leap
ahead for us especially
for the engineering.
With that, we put the security
in the middle of our process.
We make sure that the
developers are involved,
and we make sure that
we relieve the security
team from this burden.
With that, we also make sure
that we educate the developers.
There is no excuse anymore for a
developer to say I didn't know.
All the information's out there.
The vulnerability is right
in the middle of the Merge
Requests.
So when we want to
introduce a new change
in their applications and
deploy that later, it's there.
We have the
remediation information
direct in the Merge Request
so the developers can do that
themselves.
If they don't know
how to do that,
they can involve the security
team but only when needed.
With that, we are leaving
some space and some room
for our security team to
work on the very hot topics.
The ones that are
not obvious and not
the longing fruits
that-- or our tools
are able to catch
and to provide.
For every commit that we
push for our applications,
we are going to run
security checks.
We are going to do SAST,
Dependency Scanning, Container
Scanning, binary to
[INAUDIBLE] that we are going
to see after that, Dynamic
Application Security Testing,
we're during the war
package for every commit.
So again, the developers,
they have the information.
They know exactly
what's going on
and they know the
implications of their changes
on the production environments.
We want to be able, also, this
year to add IAST and Fuzzing.
If you want to take a
look at the roadmap,
there is a link at the
bottom of this slide.
You can also reach out to us.
We are an open core company,
we are completely transparent.
Our roadmap is public, you can
check out that directly online.
So all application
is not secure.
How can we trust what
we are going to deploy?
For that, we are using
Binary Authorization,
which is a container
security feature that
provides a policy
enforcement check point
to ensure only signed
and notarized images can
be deployed in production.
With that, we want
to remove completely
the human from the
deployment process.
So that the Pipeline would be
the one and only way to create
images and deploy images.
The signature is going to happen
directly in the pipeline phase.
For that, we are relying on
the Google feature name Binary
Authorization.
And under the hood,
Binary Authorization
is relying on
Grafeas and Kritis.
Grafeas is the service
to annotate the images
and Kritis is the service
to enforce the policies
and checking the signatures.
We are going to use that to
annotate the images that we
will deploy to production.
For example, with the results
of the security checks.
And if we find that some
vulnerabilities are still
shipping in this image, we can
block the deployment directly
with Kritis.
So with the Google
Binary Authorization.
this is something that
is upcoming really soon
and we're dogfooding,
obviously, at GitLab.
We're using GitLab
to develop Gitlabs,
so we are going to use
ourselves really soon.
So I told you that the Pipeline
is going to sign the image.
So that means the Pipeline
has the right keys,
the required keys, and only
the Pipeline as these keys.
So that means we need
to be able to trust
where we store these keys.
For that, we are using another
Google feature name Google Key
Management Service.
This service is not available
for all the users, only
particular users and particular
services, like the Pipeline,
are able to request keys.
We only have GKMS activated
and on production environment
right now.
But we plan we have that on
more environments in the future.
So know that your
deployment chain is secure,
application is secure,
the deployment secure.
Hackers are a bit like life,
they always find a way.
And they can compromise
our user accounts.
Even if everything
is secure, they
can always use one of our user's
account if they manage to.
So how do we mitigate that?
We can't prevent
that, obviously,
but we can limit the impact
of this compromisations.
For that, we are using User
and Entity Behavior Analytics.
It's again, a security
feature but based this time
on Machine Learning
and Data Analysis.
We're going to analyze all
the logs, all the events, all
the actions on our platform
and our environments.
And we will do that to look
for the [INAUDIBLE] unknowns,
the suspicious.
So for example, if we
have developers working
on a weekly basis, they
work from Monday to Friday,
they are located in the US.
And then suddenly on a
Saturday morning, 3:00 AM,
we have a connection,
we have a git
commit coming from Russia,
from China, at 3:00 AM.
It's really suspicious.
We need to be able
to catch this,
to notify the security
team, and to make sure
that we're going to do
further investigation,
and even to block the accounts.
But this is all
we remediate that.
All of these features
are available on GitLab.
We are again, dogfooding.
This is going to be
part of something
that we call GitLab Defend.
And again, you can check out
the links that are there.
If you want to see what's
upcoming in the roadmap
this year.
With that, back to you, Kathy.
Thank you.
KATHY WANG: Thanks, Philippe.
So now that Philippe
has talked to you
about securing our
applications, I
want to talk to you
about the third problem
that we had to face here,
which is securing GitLab.com,
which is our infrastructure.
At GitLab, this environment,
acts as both our environment
and customer data
environment, right?
We use GitLab at work.
And this is part of
our dogfooding process.
And it's very important to us
culturally to do that, dogfood
and contribute to the product.
GitLab.com is where
over two million users
have GitLab accounts.
So we want to make sure that
there is trust built in that.
People trust that we're
protecting their sensitive data
in the repos.
So what kind of information
do we need to know
and what questions do
we need to ask there?
One thing is making sure
that we always know,
have full awareness, of
vulnerability management
of our end point
devices in production.
So we looked at solutions
like Tenable.io, in our case,
just making sure that that
information is always there.
And who owns what
in the environment?
Because we dogfood all
of our own stuff, that
means that engineers,
developers are setting up
their own environments
for testing
or for whatever purpose.
And so it becomes
even more imperative
for us to know
what those are, who
owns that, who should
have access to that.
So I mentioned optics
earlier and, again, this
is a very useful tool if you
haven't looked into it based
on osquery for that.
We want to make sure
that we can mitigate
DDoS attacks and other
types of abuse-type attacks
on GitLab.com.
So to that end, we looked at
WAFs, like Fastly, Cloudflare,
for example.
That's something that we have
to do specific to GitLab.com.
And then, if an attacker
were to gain access,
how do we make it more difficult
for them to move laterally?
And by using VPCs, we
can compartmentalize
each environment in
a more clean way.
And then we can use other
tools to enforce any violations
to those access that's
coming from one environment
to another.
And what we've
done is, basically,
when those tools run,
like Forseti, results will
come into Slack, we use Slack.
And, basically, do chat
ops who report violations.
And now the security
operations team
can act on those
violations and alerts.
And then, how do we
secure our environment
using Google Security
best practices?
This is something that
Google Security research
team has thought about
for a really long time.
They're considered to be
leaders in this area, for sure.
And we want to be able to
definitely use their knowledge
about security best
practices in Google Cloud
to secure our own environment.
So we looked at tools like
Cloud Security Command Center,
that's an ongoing process.
We turn it on, we're
evaluating right now
how that works for us also.
Like I said earlier, a
policy isn't that useful
if you don't enforce.
If you don't enforce,
you're relying
on users good intentions and
we know how that goes, right?
People are human,
they make mistakes.
And that's just putting
it in a nice way.
So now that I've talked
to you, and Philippe
has talked to you about
the top three problems
that we were looking to
solve with our Zero Trust
implementation, let's
talk about roadmapping.
So since Zero Trust
is such a big topic
and it's not something
you can build right away,
it takes a long
time, it's a process.
My understanding is
that Google is still
building beyond corp. You know,
so it's a really big project.
So how do you wrap your head
around where to get started?
Well, when I started it
was like, OK, so there's
so many components, how do I
exactly want to bucketize that?
So what I did was I
worked with my team,
and decided that we're going
to do it in three buckets.
The first bucket
is anything that
will touch, store,
process, customer data
and is managed by us.
So that means our
GitLab.com infrastructure,
anything in there.
Things like that.
So that's one of our buckets
that we put components into.
The other bucket is endpoints.
Employee laptops,
devices that are
being used to access this
environment, GitLab.com
production environment, that
are individually managed.
That goes into the
endpoint bucket.
So every component that
goes towards securing that,
goes into this bucket.
The third bucket,
I mentioned that we
don't self host anything, we
rely on third-party SaS vendors
also.
So anything that does not
store or process customer data,
and that includes
like third-party apps
that we use and GitLab.
Like Slack, like
Zoom, like Salesforce,
like other third-party
apps goes into this bucket.
So that's how I began to wrap
my head around exactly how we're
going to compartmentalize this.
So based on those
three buckets, I
realized that, hey,
there's no reason why
we have to create
a roadmap where
it's kind of done in serial.
For each bucket, I'm going to
have different components that
apply to that bucket.
It's OK to build
these out in parallel.
That's actually more efficient,
it saves you more time.
You can get to the
journey faster.
And so that's how we
decided to roadmap this out.
I'm not going to read the
whole roadmap for you.
you can see for yourself.
But the point of
laying it out this way,
that's very important to make
sure you take home with you,
is things can be built
in parallel once you
bucketize how it's going to be.
So now that I've
talked about how
we began to put the roadmap
map together and start
building these components out.
Let's talk about
lessons learned so far.
I mean, obviously,
we're not totally
done building Zero Trust.
We've started and we have
some components in place.
But it's going to be a while
before we're completely
at the point where,
I would call, done
and then maintaining.
First thing to remember,
it's an ongoing exercise.
You're always gonna
get new users,
new devices, new endpoints.
Every single time that
happens, that information
needs to be updated
in your databases,
in your decision process.
Who gets access to what?
And with what device?
That's always ongoing.
Build each roadmap
map independently,
but figure out what buckets
you're going to have first.
That will be the most
efficient process to use.
We figured out, while putting
the roadmap map together,
that there are
certain components,
like centralized single sign
on, that if you get that
in place first earlier
on in the roadmap, some
of the other pieces that follow
will be more easily facilitated
because of the presence of that.
So think about things
that way, as well,
as you put numbers on
the different components
in your roadmap.
What should you do first
so that what follows
is more easily put in place.
There is an element of user
experience that a lot of people
don't realize or talk about
with building out Zero Trust.
You need to make sure you don't
impede business processes.
I mean, if you have
Zero Trust in place
but people can't
get the work done,
that's going to be a big no.
And as a security practitioner
and a security team
you'll be under a lot of
fire for that kind of thing.
So think about the user
experience as you go along.
In our case, we
decided to go with Okta
for a single sign on solution.
And that really, really
helped facilitate
the onboarding and
offboarding process.
And our sales and
our marketing teams,
they were really happy
with that because they
have so many third-party
apps that they
use that they didn't want
to sign into each one
individually, separately.
It made for really, really
good user experience
right off the start.
It helps to build user
trust, which will then
help you be able to roll
out other components later
on, which may introduce more
friction in the day to day work
process.
I'm not going to sit
up here and tell you
security never introduces
friction, it does.
But the idea is to minimize
it, make sure people trust what
you're doing, and they will if
they have a positive experience
at the beginning.
And then you can introduce
other parts of it.
But always think about that
as a security practitioner.
We realized that there
is serious automation
work that needs
to be done to make
these risk-based decisions.
Data has to be pulled
from org DB, asset DB, all
of those components to be
able to make a decision on
whether this access
is allowed or not.
So I do have a team of
security automation engineers
on my security team.
And this is what they
work on, how to automate
all of these pieces.
And that helps us scale
and it's important to scale
because we're going to grow to
over 1,000 employees this year.
And I can't imagine
these decision processes
being manual.
It shouldn't be.
Your mileage is going to vary.
As I mentioned earlier,
you can't buy one product,
slap it in, now
you got Zero Trust.
You have different
requirements, most likely.
Maybe you're not 100% remote,
maybe 50% of your employees
come to a physical
office every day.
So one size does not fit all.
And as I mentioned
earlier, who goes
BeyondCorp is a
flavor of Zero Trust.
It's a really good
learning experience
to read all of the white
papers that they have,
it's really great.
But at the end of the
day, through Google
they have a different
environment than what we had.
So we couldn't do
exactly the same thing.
It just doesn't work.
One size does not fit all.
And I want to also emphasize
that for some of you
who may come from more
mature environments
where the company has
been around for 20 years,
for example, and
perimeter-based protections
are already put in place.
It may be more of an
uphill battle for you
to lobby for Zero Trust.
I mean, everyone wants it.
And everyone knows
that it's a good model.
It's not perfect, nothing is.
But you may face more
resistance because people
don't like ripping up
what's already there.
That's difficult.
So that's maybe
a political battle for you.
In GitLab's case, because
we're growing so fast.
A year and a half ago, we didn't
have a formal security team.
Things are different.
So I want to make sure
that you know that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]